[Music]
such an amazing 2017 you're one of et's
one to watch with Ingrid goes west and
with Legion what do you have in mind for
2018 do you have any personal goals oh
wow I I don't know I just want to keep
making great things honestly like I was
so happy that the response that Ingrid
goes West God and the little hours and
and Legion and I'm just I just want to
keep kind of aiming high and not
compromising and working with brilliant
filmmakers that's really what I want
NBC has been bringing back some of their
favorite shows they're talking about
bringing back the office if they were to
talk about already already exactly so if
they were to say they wanted to even do
another revival with Parks and Rec what
would your reaction be I would say like
didn't we just end that a couple years
ago and maybe let's just wait until
we're all a little bit you know older I
don't know never mind I'll do it I'll do
it I'll do it let's do it do you miss
Janet snake-hole cuz we all do yeah I
miss Janet snake-hole I miss shauna
malwae-tweep and I miss my husband
Andy where is he I don't know whatever I
don't like labels he's a big movie star
if you kept in touch with Chris over
these years yeah of course yeah we all
do we have a little Parks and Rec tech
mass text chain that someone updates at
least every other day so yeah I love
that you all still keep in touch me
forever
honey forever
[Music]
you